awesome we're just talking about the
lineup there with you next to LeBron and
A.D and just wonder what you notice
there kind of how your size impacts that
group and what are those places you
focus when you're at the Dead yogic
yeah I feel like for for this series you
know is it different than last uh last
series you know when we were playing
against the Golden State you know they
were very very small and
uh quick and then a lot of Shooters but
um this series you know they're you know
they're almost like you know the point
guard is six six and uh everybody's like
16 and 6K so
um just got a you know the I think uh
for the the lineup that you just said
you know that's gonna you know it's
gonna be good for us and then
you know it was our first game too so
you know we're just still uh feeling the
there you know the games and everything
but yeah like I think the yeah I like
the lineup for sure
typically on you defending jokes what's
key there obviously he was incredible
the first three quarters especially yeah
you know I was just trying to
um
get in his knee you know
it was a it was just it was a it was a
part of the our game plan and we talked
about it before the game you know I'm
gonna they told me that the coaches told
me that I'm gonna go to
uh your kids too so
um you know it was I think it was a good
plan and uh
I think the second half I think I think
that we we did a pretty good job on him
and
um so yeah I think
um
yeah we got to watch the film again
tomorrow and then we're gonna come back
you said you were prepped for this
matchup by the coaching staff um how did
it Matt how to meet your expectations or
versus how you prepared for it for being
in it going up against the team I mean
yeah I'm ready you know I'm always ready
um like last game last night I got it
like I said the last series was a little
different you know it was a it wasn't
really it wasn't a real opportunity for
me so
I was ready for this moment and you know
I just had to you know uh
I I've been watching the film
um for them and then yeah I think it's
going to be big for me uh this series
you know because they I like I said you
know they they are very big and then
um they we need we need a size so you
know I think it's going to be a good one